This is the middle of a vote by the European Parliament.
Germans are eliminated or rejected
one after the other.
And. Uh,
it's about.
We'll start again in voice-over,
it will be easier.
And the challenge of the day,
is to explain to you in less than 2 minutes
what the European Parliament is for.
It is in this emicycle,
at the headquarters of Strasbourg,
debated by seven hundred and five euros in deputies,
including 79 French.
Him, for 5 years,
together,
it represents nearly
quatre-cent-cinquante-millions of Europeans.
The Euro members meet here 12 times a year,
generally once a month,
for 3 and a half days,
during what are called full sessions.
The rest of the time,
he works mainly in Brussels.
Parliament,
it is the only institution of the European Union
directly elected by the citizens,
and for the last 45 years.
Each country is represented by 1 number of deputies
different according to its number of inhabitants.
And MPs are not grouped by country,
but by political group
sharing ideas in common.
I promise,
we will present them to you in the next video.
First,
I need to explain what I meant by,
In fact,
the zero MPs have 3 major powers,
the power of control,
budgetary and legislative powers
which he shares with the Council of the European Union.
The advice is 1 other
institution of the European Union which
represents the governments of the member states.
Together, these 2
institutions vote and therefore
adopt the laws of the European Union.
These laws are called the Guidelines,
and they are
important because they are theoretically more important
on the national law of each country.
However, be careful,
parliament cannot itself
propose European laws.
This is the European Commission,
1 kind of
European government that always has the initiative.
This is what is often blamed on the
functioning of the European Union,
parliament must then debate its laws,
and almond almonds,
it doesn't mean fines,
but it means changing the text of the law.
For example,
suggest a more ambitious goal than had
proposed by the commission,
it's minus 30%,
no, it's minus 40%.
This modification work,
they do it in a smaller group,
called
parliamentary commission
and who are specialized on the subject concerned.
They talk for several months in Brussels,
and when the text is ready,
they submit it to the full house vote,
that is,
the seven hundred and five deputies in the
music of Strasbourg.
And there,
there is still the possibility of
modify the text by proposing new
abandonments.
Yes, I know,
it's a little complicated.
We,
the moment we arrived in the missiles,
they were just voting
or reject dozens of
and dozens of ornaments,
freehand or with their of votes
on 1 new law for the
promotion of the repair of consumer goods.
There, now
you know a little more about why
next elections
are important.
But don't hesitate to subscribe if you want.
everything you need to know before the elections
the new/06.